thank you for coming my Todd I'm gonna
start out with just a few
fully these are not new to you the first
one is data integration and what I mean
by this is you trying to build one
source of data from multiple other
sources and you want it to be cleaner
and more timely and more correct and you
have links back to the original data so
that you can you can get to it if you
need to second application is what I'm
calling enrichment and the idea here is
that you have some data set already
built and get data from the client you
match that client data to your own data
and then pass them back some bit of
information that they didn't already
have you know maybe an identifier that
they need the third one which is which
is pretty common in in many industries
is well I'm just going to call record
linkage and the basic idea here is that
you want to match records together not
so much because of the identities of the
records but because of the data that you
have associated with them this happens a
lot in like medical research and
financial the financial world I'm going
to use this concept throughout of what's
called pairwise matching and the basic
idea is that you have two sets of data
theoretically you want to look at every
conceivable pair of records in both data
sets there's one subset of that cross
product that is matches one subsets
which is which are the non matches in
practice you don't look at all the data
you figure out some way to index it or
pre cluster or whatever this is this is
not yes this isn't actually the software
architecture that you would necessarily
use either in most cases you'll have
some pre-established database and you
read any data trying to match to that
but I'm going to use this this concept
the alternative way of looking at
matching is the clustering approach
where you start off with a set of data
or a combined set of data and you try to
build clusters from that which is
especially appropriate for deduplication
but in practice the
computational complexity and the actual
detail worth you happy to is very
similar in each case the test data that
I'm gonna use is from a blog post from a
few months ago by the guys at in de Gama
and what they did was they took a data
set from the health department in
Florida with aims but were there
inspecting restaurants and they took a
data set from the Department of Labor on
wage violations and they connected those
together to see if there was a
correlation between a company failing to
employ pay their employees correctly and
health violations in those restaurants
the short answer is yes there is a
correlation which is nice thanks so the
first step I'm gonna run through is what
I'm gonna call profiling profiling is a
huge set of things which covers a lot of
stuff that I won't do here but what I'm
really looking for is keys in the in
datasets that I can use to connect them
up we want to see if they're if they're
accurate if there's if there are enough
of them to use for matching are they in
a consistent format and in some cases
you know are they recent I might have
several records for the same data some
of them may be really old I use my own
use pandas for all this if I suspect a
lot of you were already familiar with it
pandas has a has a command on the data
frame called info and obviously this is
a little more info than you would you
would want to know this is all the
columns and the health inspection data
what you're really looking for is things
that you might use as identifiers and
also the information on the right-hand
side tells you you know which of those
are non null so to sort of pare this
down a little bit you can you can choose
the things that you think are probably
identifiers drop the identical
duplicates and they can be data for any
and that's all I've done here for this
for the restaurant data so the that's
stuff on the right-hand side tells you
how many non nulls you have there so if
those were
you know 90% null and that would
probably not be a good feel for magic on
and this is this is a similar data for
the similar command for the wage data
some more interesting things you can do
a lot of times you have numeric fields
in your data and you want to see if they
follow some pattern so the case I've
used as zip codes both both data sources
have zip codes it's all I'm doing is
reducing the zip code field to a
specific pattern then grouping on that
pattern and looking at the counts so you
can see in in the restaurant data they
have both 5 & 9 digit zips which they've
put into two different forms and in the
second one they have they have five
digit zips but since they're all numbers
pandas by default interprets that as a
floating point as a in 64 and the
pattern comes up looking like looking
like a float but it's five digits it you
can do slightly more sophisticated
things I didn't have a good example for
this data set but you can also use apply
with regular expressions this might be a
good way to for instance check the email
addresses are in the proper format or
dates or in a particular format all I
did here was look at the leading pattern
on the on the names to see if I had
mixed case
another thing you can do with pandas is
it has a filter capability which is kind
of like group by having and sequel and
so this is just looking for cases in the
in the the restaurant data where the
name of the company on the address and
the city are all the same and and
looking at those and identifying ones
aware that those occur more than once
just to see if you still have duplicates
in these data sources as they stand
which which we do another thing you can
potentially do is the series in in
pandas has yes these are once you boiled
them down to just the location data just
the identifier data one set is about 54
thousand rows and the other is 17
thousand rows or things so you know
pretty small and in general pandas is
gonna work on things that fit in memory
but no you can get a two terabyte
instant-on instance on Amazon
lots of stuff it's a memory so so the
series has a thing called value counts
which just gives you a list of the most
common things what I used the example I
used here was the the DOL data has both
a trade name and a legal name and it's
not immediately clear to me at least
which one of those you might want to use
as the name so if you look at the value
accounts on legal name those don't look
recognizable to me but if you look at
the counts on trade name those look like
businesses to me also pandas you can
make nice graphs with and this is a case
where these are these name strings I
want to compare a lot of times when
you're doing matching things you'll find
that in the original data source the the
person who built the data said this is
going to be the name failed but I'm only
going to dedicate twenty characters to
it and so what happens is that half the
you know half and half the words in the
name are abbreviations and so if you you
know this might
be a useful way to determine that your
names aren't really closely comparable
which it seems like they probably are
here so the next step the the thing we
have to figure out is how to compare
these records next what we really want
is a function that will take any record
pair and tell us yes this is a match or
no this is not a match we could of
course do that if we if we restrict
ourselves to identical matches but in
practice what happens is you compare the
fields in each record usually using some
sort of similarity function sometimes
it's it's on it's identical comparison
but it's usually some sort of some sort
of distance metric the string similarity
function or other distance metrics and
what you end up with is what is usually
called a comparison vector and then from
those comparison vectors you you make
decisions about what isn't-isn't to
match the first thing you typically have
to do to your data before you do these
comparisons is some sort of
pre-processing and I'm not gonna spend a
lot of time on this because I think
you've probably all done it or seen it
in some form or another but it's usually
things like you know standardizing on a
particular case and removing
abbreviations standardizing on a zip
format parsing things in sometimes it's
called segmenting things into pieces so
that you can prepare them more easily
and this is just you know that's the
simple way I've done it on on my test
data with with pandas using apply and
and you know lower icing fields and
taking sub strings this is a trick I
just covered recently with pandas where
I really like where you can actually
split the strings so I just threw that
in here because I think it's cool
so probably the most the most well
developed area of similarity comparison
is in string string comparisons and
there's a bunch of string similarity
metrics or functions and these are just
some that you have available to you in
Python the ones that are highlighted
there the ones that I'm going to look at
in more detail the jellyfish library in
particulars is very useful for to me at
least for data matching so Levenstein or
at a distance you've probably all seen
it in some context before it's kind of a
basic computer science thing basically
the Edit distance is the number of one
character edits you have to make to get
from one string to another then you know
that I've just transformed PI data into
Panda by making pandas by making one
character edits in this slide the next
two I'm going to talk about are called
the yaro and the ero winkler one and I'm
gonna show you in a little more detail
just because I don't think they're
well-known there they're not used a lot
in in other machine learning or
statistics applications but they're used
a lot in in data matching and record
linkage this these both came out of the
Census Bureau I believe that's the basic
form of the the RO similarity metric and
then the R Winkler variation of that
just takes the same thing but puts more
emphasis on the initial part of the
string especially when you're looking at
businesses that turns out to be very
useful another one that comes up a lot
in a lot of context even in the
clustering machine learning is Jaccard
similarity which again you're probably
familiar with it's just the the ratio of
the intersection of the sets to the
union of the sets the nice thing about
this particular method is that you can
use it on strings you can use it on
tokens and quite often you use it on on
engrams or what are called shingles and
in some some applications which is what
I've done there on the bottom so I just
means you're taking overlap
in subsets of the string and comparing
so what I'm trying to show here is how
effective these things are this this
presumes I've already done the matching
and so this is on the the data after
I've done the matching on the test data
the graph on the Left shows the scores
for the matches for each metric and you
can see that the yarra link Lowen gives
you pretty good scores on the matches
and then the right-hand side are the
scores on the top I think it's the top
1000 non matches and so what I'm trying
to convey here is that the our Winkler
metric gives you really good separation
so it gives you relatively lower scores
on the non matches and relatively higher
scores on the matches look again that
won't be true on every data set but in
data matching applications especially
with businesses and sometimes human
names that's often the case there's
there's again a bunch more sophisticated
versions of these one that I would
particularly recommend looking at if
you're interested in this is what's
called soft tf-idf which is just an
extension of term frequency inverse
document frequency approach but using in
using it in conjunction with other
similarity metrics it's actually
probably the best one that I know of the
best similarity metric that I know of
but it's considerably more work than the
other human names human names are among
the more tricky things to match I don't
have any human names in my test data so
I took some examples from some financial
advisory data these are actual this is
actual data taken from actual Department
of Labor and other data sources and
these are all all do refer to the same
guy you can see some of the common
things you know people make mistakes
they there's OCR errors they they you
know concatenate things together and
then the kicker is if you if you google
for this guy yeah
by Rick which again is a tricky tricky
thing with human names so just some
advice on human names if they come in
your data source if they come as a
single string you almost always want to
parse them out it's they're easier it's
easier to compare things that way based
on my own experience don't try to use a
regex to do that because you will go
insane if you're trying to be really
precise substituting first-name does a
useful thing to do it's one morning
there is that there are databases of
first-name alternatives on on the
internet I would not start with those
sometimes they'll have you know 200
alternatives for a first name and that
would just blow things up for you if
you're doing this as part of the data
product or an ongoing process a lot of
times you just have to make a dictionary
of matches that you found previously and
do lookups and then finally sometimes it
might be more you might have data that
has a name and also the employer might
be more useful to figure out who exactly
who the employer is first and then use
that as a data point to match against
the names there is a there's a good
Python library for doing name parsing
which does a pretty good job in a lot of
cases it's called name parser people
have also backed package this into an
online service as you can see here it
does a pretty good job on a pretty you
know sophisticated a long name with
titles and prefixes and so forth however
it is purely syntax based so if you have
a case like this where it's its last
name first if you don't have the comma
in there it's not going to know that
that richard is a more common name it's
just going to assume that the guy's name
is the fruit guys first name is brighter
addresses addresses are even potentially
trickier you know a good thing about
addresses is there's this huge body of
work having been done on geographical
information systems over the years I
think I'll just skip ahead to the
geocoding stuff but one one note of
warning is just because something has
the same address doesn't mean it's the
same it's the same business
I call this the foodcourt effect which
you can sort of see here there's also an
interesting little catch there there's
there's an incorrect as if good in this
data so geo coder czar basically divided
tools that take an address and give you
back the latitude and longitude and
other information potentially and they
also parse the address there's a bunch
of them
Google's is probably the best but it's
not free most of these services are not
free there is a geo coder called Tiger
which is an add-on to the post GIS
extension to Postgres and it works
pretty well but you have to set it up
yourself and you have to get the data
from the Census Bureau I've shown here
an example of how you invoke Tiger from
from PC cool and you can see it just
give it address and it gives you various
bits of information about that address
the trick with geo coders is that
they're only as good as what you give
them in input so you can see there on
this table there's a rating value and
most geo coder will return some sort of
rating that says yeah I know where this
is you can trust this latitude and
longitude but if you give it a if you
give it a incorrect address and can't
find that it will give you a rating that
says you know this may not be where you
think it is and if it gives you a really
high rating it's probably saying I don't
have enough information determine this
precisely so in the last case I'm just
giving it the name of a city so it's
probably giving something like the
center of that of the area bounded by
that zip code just quickly to actually
compare the distance between two places
you have to do it's it's called the
Great Circle distance in practice you
don't really need to do that for
matching because you don't really care
exactly how far apart they are just are
they close
there's a lot been a lot of work on on
segmenting addresses and names using
sophisticated techniques like hidden
Markov models and conditional random
fields I that's yeah again I talked into
in and of itself so I didn't want to go
into that in detail
um I mentioned earlier than this in his
pairwise matching approach you're you
conceptually looking every possible pair
in practice you can't always do that
even in our relatively small data sets
here we've got around 800 or 900 million
record pairs so you do this process of
blocking which means doing some sort of
pre clustering to eliminate all of the
obvious non matches sort of a
conventional way to do that which
doesn't work that well on in a lot of
cases is to generate what's called the
soundex code for the name you can see
here I've generated soundex codes for
all the names and both sources and
there's at least one there where it
matches up so if you if you were to use
the soundex as the blocking code it
would you'd only have to match within
this set instead of each name across
each set sometimes you can just use the
key properties for instance this is if
you use the zip code this isn't the
whole data set but that red band there
is essentially the ones you would have
to match if you just things use things
where the zip code was the same not
everything that's in blue you can throw
away the problem with that obviously is
that you you miss matches because
there's going to be some actual matches
that don't have the same zip code so a
lot of times you use more than one of
the keys you use the zip and maybe the
street number and something else you
also in one details you may have to do
that and sequentially rather than making
one big set of data and match me after
you to get the statistics right on some
of the later techniques you may have to
do that in stages another thing that
works pretty well on on messier name
data is what are called Engram based
blocks and the basic idea here again is
you take engrams in my case I have
diagrams you take some
you take the diagrams of the string and
then you take some subset of those and
put them into a chunk and that serves as
basically a key and an inverted index I
made this picture hoping that it would
be a little bit clearer what's happening
the things on the left are basically the
index elements so they're they're sets
of diagrams that have been pushed put
together into lengths of a 16 character
string and those two names there they
are in fact the same place and you can
see that they they share that top like
that top key there again this is a
really big field there's a thousand
different ways to do this the canopy
clustering is used my I have not
personally used as myself and my
understanding is it's kind of difficult
to get the thresholds right to make this
work but it's sort of like a pre
clustering approach um
locality-sensitive hashing particular
min hash if you don't know min hash look
it up it's it's one of my favorite ideas
in computer science and can be used to
to do this blocking operation and
there's been the gentleman in the
audience we did a really good density
based clustering talk yesterday we
really do pain example on you know so
there's a lot of clustering approaches
it can be used for blocking as well okay
now the the last step is we've we've
made these comparison vectors and we
have to figure out are these things a
match or not the four things I'm going
to hopefully talk about our simple
scoring rules based probabilistic
matching and and just supervised
learning mostly on the probabilistic
matching stuff because that's that's the
most interesting I think simple scoring
means you just you have this vector of
similarity metrics you add them up you
say anything above a certain threshold
is match anything below is not a match
that actually works reasonably well on
our data set this this shows what this
shows is the blue is the matches and the
red is the top non matches so you can
see it does separate them
somewhat but there is this this area of
overlap between like 2.7 and 2.9 where
there where both there's both non
matches and matches and the real issue
with this is not so much that there's
this overlap but it doesn't really the
problem with it is you doesn't really
tell you anything about where the
boundary should be another really common
approach is using rules and there are
ways to learn rules from the data but a
lot of times these are just made from
people who know something about the data
to begin with the main benefit of this
over just the basic simple scoring is
that you can you can use multiple rules
for different situations so you can say
you know if similarity in the name is
over 0.8 and the zip code is the same
I'm going to assume that's a match but
you could also say if the similarities
over 9.5 I'm going to regard it as a
match irrespective of what the zip code
is so you can and these get relatively
complicated so there's this idea of
probabilistic matching which has
actually been around since I think the
1960s and these these two gentlemen
Falacci and Center did a paper in the
60s I believe that detailed this idea so
in this case our comparison vector is
basically a set of predicates so what
I've used here is the first predicate is
the name is over a certain threshold the
zip is equal and and the Eleven Stein
distance between the street numbers is
less than two and given that comparison
vector there's eight possible patterns
that you could see I've just Delaney
ated them there in this little data
frame table the basic idea is that
certain of those patterns are much more
common in in the match set of matches
and some of them are much more common
instead of non matches and so they
define these two conditional
probabilities M nu M is the probability
you see that match from the match set
use the probability you see that pattern
and
non-match that and then with using that
data you make what they call a linkage
rule which again is just the thresholds
that you pick to determine what's a
match what's a non match and what needs
to be reviewed and sort of their insight
was that they they showed that these
ratios can be used to define given the
data that you have these ratios can be
used to find essentially optimal linkage
rule given the level of error that
you're willing to accept so you know if
you say I'm willing to accept one out of
a thousand incorrect matches then you
could you can adjust these thresholds
and given them given them over you
ratios to get the optimal set for that
level of error so there's two two
simplifications that are always almost
always made of this approach one is to
assume conditional independence between
the properties and then the other one
which is probably not as important these
days is you take the logs of the ratios
to do is to make a score that just means
you don't have to multiply the
individual conditional probabilities
together you can just sum them so you've
probably noticed that this method sort
of depends on actually knowing what's in
the EM set and what's in the use that to
begin with which is would kind of defeat
the purpose if we already knew that
there are some ways to do that that I've
just involved knowing something about
the data and progressing we refine
progressively refining it but the
technique that people have arrived at
over the years to do this in a more
precise way is the expectation
maximization algorithm yen algorithm the
basic idea here is that the distribution
of patterns in our data set is a mixture
of some parameters in this case it's the
M parameters the U parameters and some
extra parameter called P which is
actually the the probability of a match
being in the set it's also called the
nixing parameter so if you've used like
Gaussian mixture models in scikit-learn
I think it uses the e/m approach and
this this P parameter is called mixing
parameter then the method then next
assumes that there's this latent hidden
variable that tells you that determines
which set it's in and then once you have
that you just have to basically find the
parameters that maximize the the
likelihood function which is you know
pretty simple that wasn't supposed to be
funny okay this is actually fairly easy
to do though the it looks it looks a
little nasty but normally you take the
log of this and do use log likelihood
and it it actually is pretty easy to
program if you look up the if you look
up the papers where they develop this
method that the calculations you need to
do to do this or not particularly owners
so I can't actually run it here it takes
a few minutes to run but this is
basically the sort of data that you end
up with in this particular case we end
up with a pretty large set of possible
matches which is unfortunate but you can
you can pretty much assume anything
where the where all three or that you
have the 1 1 1 pattern you can probably
assume those are those are good matches
there's according to the the EM
algorithm those those are only about 1
in 1 in 10 billion roughly but the rest
of them might require some sort of
clerical review and there are sort of
ways to to do optimize this but I've
always worked I've always worked in
situations where I had a data team
available to do the clerical review on
the near matches and if there's you know
10,000 of them that's something that a
team can get through pretty quickly or
you can use something like CrowdFlower
so you can use you know normal
supervised learning classification
approaches on this stuff the trick is
that you need you know label data but
that's not as that's not as unusual as
you'd imagine because you can often you
know start with this with a set of data
and use that to train and then you know
just use the here I've used like the
psychic learned random forest classifier
there is one trick with this which is
that it's hugely unbalanced so even if
you've even if you've indexed the set
and reduced the number of things that
you want to match in this particular
case I find about 1300 matches and the
the reduced set is as well over a
million of the comparisons that I had to
make and the other problem is that the
the distribution of things in the non
match set is not it's not very even and
so there's two things you can do which
is one is you can you can try to
restrict yourself to just using non
matches that are closed which has
certain problems or you can there's
probably not an optimal way to do it you
kind of have to get a set of data which
has as things that what you want to
distinguish between is the things that
are matches in closed non matches but
what happens is you end up in this
particular situation even though it's
about 94% accurate and this in this
cross-validation if you look at the if
you look at the feature importance is
down there at the bottom
basically all it's doing here is
optimizing the string similarity
distance I
this graph requires a little bit of
explanation but the basic what I was
trying to convey here is that on the y
axis is the simple scores that we used
you know several slides ago and you can
see there's not a big there's not a big
range of those so just just eyeballing
you probably wouldn't separate those two
things but the the random forest
classifier does a pretty good job the
things on the right are the thing in red
are the thing that are matches and so
that the x-axis is the probability of it
being a match according to the to the
classifier so it does a pretty decent
job of figuring out which is which using
isn't a match a final few things to look
into if this interests you what one is
and the probabilistic matching you can
make a lot of modifications to that and
one is that you can take into account
the fact that certain certain patterns
in the data are less likely so if you're
doing say a name match if you find a
match between two two guys named sniff
that's a less interesting match than
then you know many other names there's
there's a couple of tools now which use
an approach called active learning which
is basically what you start out you
start out with a training set and it
separates this the fairly obvious
different things from each other and
then it goes through a process of saying
I don't know about this one is this a
match or a non match and so you you run
through you know it'll prompt you with
several examples and after you've run
through you know maybe a hundred of
those it'll be trained to to recognize
those things that are kind of in your
matches there's a there's a product
called be dupe that's hosted by data
main I think that that does this and
it's a pretty cool tool it was based on
a gentleman's master's thesis so there's
there's also a pretty detailed
paper on it and then there's a program
called febrile I I'm assuming that South
pronounced it's a Python program that
was used for record lane linkage it was
written it's from Australia and it was
used for medical biomedical record
linkage it has some of the Fuji Center
stuff in it so it's another good
resource to look at oh yeah that the
gentleman who wrote is primarily
responsible for that package also wrote
what's probably the best book on data
matching which is descriptively called
data matching i think his name is Peter
Christians and Christians Kristen okay
yeah good book I recommend it I think
that's all I have
well industries in particular there are
industry identifiers that have a sort of
distance to them like makes codes and
codes and things like that there's sort
of a hierarchy so they're like they're
like zip codes where the initial part of
the code describes the industry broadly
and and the the you know that as you get
into more detail it gets more specific
about the industry but I'd have to think
I don't have a good answer for ya yeah I
know what you mean I just don't have a
good answer for it
yeah
so a transposition in particular is just
two letters that are switched so if you
if you have two strings and you take one
of them and you switch the two letters
there's a trap whether that would be one
transport transposition difference
between the two does that does that help
yeah yeah they have to be consecutive
yeah the reason why that's in there in
particular a lot of these at distance
metrics were specifically built to just
to address the fact that this data was
entered primarily by humans and you know
sometimes by hand and sometimes with
computers but a human is most likely to
make a one digit or one letter will
transfer to the transposition
sure so they are basically it's
basically an alternative term for Engram
so which can be applied to both
sequences of characters and sequences of
tokens so they call them shingles
because they overlap like the shingles
on a roof so if you if you were looking
at diagrams for instance you take the
first two characters of the word and
that's the first diagram and you take
the second third character of the word
that's the second diagram those those
are also called shingles and they can be
of you know arbitrary length as long as
it's less than the length of the actual
string their sequence they're basically
they give you a little bit of more
structure to the to the to the data so
if you're with Jaccard distance in
particular since it's just a set based
thing you can have you can have two
words that would that in terms of
Jaccard similarity would be identical
because they have the same characters
but they would they might not they would
clearly not be the same word but if you
use diagrams or shingles then you're
adding you're giving some structure to
that sequence and so the two things that
are the same set of characters but don't
have the same sequence with score low or
using the shingles again this is a this
is an idea that comes up in Manhattan
Cali sensitive hashing things so it's
it's there's a paper from the 90s by
Andre Broder which is really cool on
this idea
why is it why is it what oh I think it's
subtracting the number of trans
positions from the number of common
characters yeah I'm pretty sure it's
supposed to be a subtraction but I I
can't I can't explain necessarily why
true yeah
well I think that I think what it's
trying to capture is that it people
sometimes make the the transposition
error
yeah I see what you're saying yeah yeah
I can't answer your question
thank you